A NEW TORNADO WATCH IS IN EFFECT
THIS MORNING FOR 8 MILLION
PEOPLE IN TEXAS, ARKANSAS AND
LOUISIANA.
>>> OF THE COUNTLESS HORRIFYING
STORIES THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
UKRAINE, MANY OF THEM INVOLVE
CHILDREN.
THE IMAGES THAT YOU ARE ABOUT TO
SEE ARE DISTURBING, I WILL WARN
YOU.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE WORLD TO
SEE THE FACES OF THESE CHILDREN
AND TO HEAR THEIR STORIES.
THESE ARE PICTURES TAKEN OF THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
DOCTORS ALLOWING THE BRITISH
PUBLICATION THE TELEGRAPH TO
PUBLISH THEM, SAYING THEY HOPE
THE IMAGES MAKE A STRONG
IMPRESSION ON THE WORLD ABOUT
THE HORRORS OF WAR, PARTICULARLY
ON ITS YOUNGEST VICTIMS.
JOINING ME TO EXPLAIN THE PHOTOS
IN GREATER DETAIL IS ONE OF THE
REPORTERS ON THE STORY,
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALIST TONYA
KOZARIVA.
THESE ARE TOUGH PICTURES TO LOOK
AT.
THESE KIDS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THIS, THE BIGGEST VICTIMS OF
THIS.
CAN YOU TELL US THEIR STORYS?
TELL US ABOUT MASHA AND TO BE
CLEAR, THE HEADLINE IS MASHA IS
15, HER BODY IS BROKEN AND
RUSSIANS SAY SHE'S A FAKE.
TELL US ABOUT MASHA.
>> SO THE WHOLE -- THE WHOLE
SCENE THAT WE WITNESSED, IT WAS
HORRIBLE, AND A NIGHTMARE.
WE ENTERED THIS ROOM, INTENSIVE
CARE ROOM OF THE REGIONAL
ZAPORIZHZHIA HOSPITAL AND THERE
WAS THREE KIDS.
AND ALL OF THEM, LIKE, TWO OF
THEM WAS NOT IN CONSCIOUS AND
MASHA WAS THE ONLY ONE WHO, YOU
KNOW, WHO WAS REACTING ON WHAT
IS GOING ON.
SHE -- SHE COULD SPEAK, BUT WE
DECIDED NOT TO DISTURB HER.
AND WE JUST SAW, YOU KNOW, THIS
GRIM PICTURE OF VERY YOUNG AND
BEAUTIFUL UKRAINIAN GIRL WHO IS
ONLY 15 YEARS OLD.
BUT WHO ALREADY HAD HER RIGHT
KNEE AMPUTATED, HER RIGHT LEG
AMPUTATED ABOVE THE KNEE, AND
HER RIGHT HAND IS ALSO SHREDDED
BY THE SHRAPNEL THAT GOT INTO
THERE -- GOT INTO HER.
AND MASHA, I HAD TO TELL YOU,
MASHA IS FROM A SMALL TOWN NEAR
ZAPORIZHZHIA, AND IT IS A TOWN
WHERE THERE IS NO -- MILITARY
OBJECTS.
AND SHE JUST CAUGHT THE SHRAPNEL
INTO HER BODY WHILE SHE WAS
WALKING AROUND HER TOWN WITH HER
MOTHER.
SO MOTHER COVERED HER FROM THE
SHRAPNEL, BUT AS HER GRANDMOTHER
TOLD US THE STORY, THE STORY,
THIS GRIM STORY, SHE TOLD US HER
MOTHER COVERED HER DAUGHTER, BUT
WHEN SHE, YOU KNOW, WHEN SHE
WOKE UP, SHE SAW, YOU KNOW,
BLOOD AND VERY GRIM PICTURE.
AND WHEN WE SPOKE TO
GRANDMOTHER, TO MASHA'S
GRANDMOTHER, SHE WAS CRYING.
VALENTINA, SHE IS CRUSHED, I
THINK, FOREVER, BECAUSE TWO
DEAREST MEMBERS OF HER FAMILY
HAD THIS WOUND FOREVER.
>> AND IN YOUR STORY, TANYA, WE
SEE THE GRANDMOTHER, THE PAIN ON
HER FACE.
YOU ALSO INTRODUCE YOUR READERS
TO MALANA, AN 11-YEAR-OLD, WHO
IS WOUNDED AND IS ATTACHED TO A
VENTILATOR, ONE OF THE CHILDREN
WHO IS UNCONSCIOUS.
I THINK ONE OF THE STUNNING
THINGS ABOUT THIS IS RUSSIANS
DON'T BELIEVE THESE ARE REAL.
RIGHT, TANYA?
>> YES.
MALANA'S STORY, IT IS EVEN
WORSE, IF IT CAN BE EVEN
COMPARED, PROBABLY NOT.
MALANA -- HER FATHER WAS ON THE
WAY FROM MARIUPOL.
SO THEY SURVIVED THE SIEGE.
THEY SURVIVED THIS MORE THAN 20
DAYS WITH NO FOOD, NO
ELECTRICITY, NO WATER, YOU KNOW.
AND AFTER ALL THIS THEY WERE ON
THE WAY, THEY, YOU KNOW, THEY
WERE ON THE WAY TO ZAPORIZHZHIA
AND THEIR CAR WAS SHELLED ON
THIS BIG QUEUE OF CARS THAT WAS
TRYING TO ESCAPE THE SIEGE.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE CASES
THAT, YOU KNOW, THAT WE SAW, AND
IT WAS ONE OF THE CASES WHEN THE
CIVILIANS IN THE CARS WERE
TRYING TO ESCAPE, THERE WERE,
YOU KNOW, THEY HAD -- THEY
BASICALLY, AGAIN, THEY'RE
DAMAGED FOREVER, I THINK.
YES, BUT THE STORY HERE IS ALSO
VERY IMPRESSIVE JUST BECAUSE THE
HEAD OF THIS INTENSIVE CARE, THE
HOSPITAL, HE TOLD US THAT, YOU
KNOW, THAT MANY OF HIS FRIENDS
AND MANY UKRAINIANS WILL SHARE
THIS EXPRESSION WITH HIM.
MANY OF HIS RUSSIAN FRIENDS
DOESN'T BELIEVE THAT THOSE
PICTURES IS REAL, NO THOSE
STORIES ABOUT WOUNDED PEOPLE AND
WOUNDED PEOPLE AND KILLED KIDS,
THEY'RE, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE FAKE
STORIES THAT UKRAINIANS ARE
MAKING THEM UP, JUST IN ORDER TO
IMPRESS SOMEBODY OR IMPRESS THE
WORLD, BUT THIS IS REAL, THIS IS
WHAT IS REALLY -- WE AS A
JOURNALIST, WITNESSED AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT DOCTORS, AS
THEY TOLD US, NEVER SAW EVER
BEFORE.
THEY NEVER HAVE SEEN KIDS IN
THIS KIND OF CONDITIONS, AND
HEAVILY WOUNDED.
>> AND, TANYA, THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THIS IMPORTANT WORK WITH
US.
BECAUSE I KNOW SOME PEOPLE
AREN'T GOING TO BELIEVE IT, NO
MATTER WHAT, BUT WHEN YOU'RE
DOING THIS REPORTING AND YOU'RE
SHOWING THESE PICTURES THERE ARE
GOING TO BE SOME PEOPLE THAT
LO